what's going on guys this is rob and i
understand that like galactus and these
guys fantastic four all that kind of
stuff is not necessarily a major talking
point right now but it is something that
i want to discuss here right so i have
no idea if this video is going to be
successful or not honestly i don't
really care but it is something i want
to talk about and the reason why is
because one of you guys tweeted at me
yesterday at least the time this video
was being recorded and said that you
thought that galactus should basically
just be a celestial who defected from
the other celestials and just like went
off and did his own thing and then you
even went as far as to say that you felt
like nor rad the silver surfer could be
like an eternal that basically got
cosmic powers not 100 sure i feel about
the idea of nor rad being an eternal i i
really much enjoy the notion that like
nor rad sacrificed his humanity for lack
of a better word he's actually from a
planet called zen law so basically he's
called a zen loving uh but he basically
sacrificed his
autonomy his agency in order to work as
a herald of galactus to like save his
own world which doesn't matter because
his own world got consumed later on
anyway but the important thing here is
that uh the idea of galactus being a
celestial that defected is cool and the
reason why is because one of the biggest
issues you have in marvel comics if you
look at galactus objectively he doesn't
really make any sense right the
existence of galactus is just weird
right and it just doesn't it defies any
real logical reason right and the reason
why i say that is it's full of guys who
are familiar with galactus bear with me
here for a second for those of you guys
who aren't over comics explain we have
like a full-on video explaining the
history of the characters so that's way
more in-depth than what i'll tell you
here but he's basically the survivor of
like a previous iteration of the
universe right when that universe came
to an end he basically merged with that
universe's sentience and then was reborn
into the new universe as galactus now in
more recent years that's been changed by
guys like donnie cates with like the
black winter and galactus is actually a
herald of the black women it doesn't
really matter right classic definition
he's the survivor of a dead universe who
was reborn into this universe with just
a ridiculous level of power but the
reality is that he just travels around
the universe consuming life-sustaining
worlds and he does this because it's his
role in the universe and that's it that
was established in the old trial of read
richard's storyline right when reid
richards was put on trial by the various
empires of the universe for saving the
life of galactus and by doing so dooming
unnamed trillions of of people to death
when their worlds were consumed by
galactus and then in the middle of all
that eternity the cosmic entity shows up
grants everybody cosmic awareness and
says this is the role galactus plays
it's what he's supposed to do shut the
hell up and let reed go uh and and they
did right they basically ended up you
know cutting them loose
but the reality is galactus doesn't
really make sense when you look at him
objectively right the guy travels around
the universe he consumes life-sustaining
worlds because reasons and like that's
it right that's all you really get in
marvel comics but if you if you take the
concept of galactus and you were to
throw him like that into the mcu people
would accept it but they would also kind
of wonder like what's like what's the
point of this guy like what
is that that's it it's just it's just
what he's supposed to do right he just
does that because that's just what he's
supposed to do people would probably
want a little more logic and a little
more reason behind it right and so if
you take this this notion that galactus
was actually a celestial say for example
the gardener and basically defected and
then maybe went crazy or whatever it is
it would make a lot more sense and the
reason why is because the celestials
themselves do have individual roles
right you may have picked up on that
from the eternals film i don't know
maybe you're one of the many people who
fell asleep during that movie but during
the during the film they do establish
the fact that the celestials have
individual roles and the comics is the
exact same way right you have like the
one above all celestial not to be
confused with the one above all god also
known as keanu reeves uh that guy is
like the the whole like kitten caboodle
creator of everything in existence the
one above all celestial is just the
leader of the celestials and that's it
he's not that important more important
than the one above all celestial is
actually arishim the judge right as you
guys probably figured out from the
eternals film irish in the judge's job
is to literally show up on a world where
they've conducted experiments and decide
are the experiments a success or a
failure if it's considered as a failure
they completely cleanse the world they
sanitize the whole thing and then
basically start over again if it's
considered a success they allow it to
continue on now the gardener is the one
that actually plants life on that world
right like seeds that world with life
and so on and so forth and so it's
entirely possible you could simply just
say that much like the deviants were
basically the force that was created by
the celestials to essentially get rid of
alpha predators and then in turn the
deviants became alpha predators
themselves or apex predators themselves
that galactus was at one point basically
the gardener right he was there to like
sustain worlds right to to put life in
those worlds there's room for that
because in recent years in marvel comics
really during al ewing's ultimate
storyline so basically the the
multiversal avengers team that had like
adam brashear and black panther and
monica rambo and carol danvers uh and
america chavez right it was a
ridiculously overpowered team they
basically captured like they fought and
defeated galactus so that gives you any
indication of how powerful they are and
then they totally re-materialized and
basically completed his evolution they
called him and then turned him into the
lifebringer so he basically started
traveling around the universe creating
life on worlds right seeding like seeing
life on different worlds you can easily
say that was the original role of
galactus when he existed in the universe
he was one of the celestials he planted
life on worlds basically allows them to
grow and flourish and then somewhere
along the line something went wrong and
then he basically started consuming life
from worlds and then now he's galactus
he travels around the cosmos destroying
life-sustaining worlds how long you
could go on with that i'm not entirely
sure it's entirely possible like that's
his origin in the mcu and then basically
the the kind of finality of galactus is
that he's not destroyed because he can't
really be destroyed by any of the
superheroes on earth or really anybody
in the universe and so that's just the
role he has and every once in a while he
comes along and like things pop off and
they gotta like get him to go away and
then that's basically it right and then
you could easily take that and just tie
the silver surfer into it and say like
on some world somewhere out in the far
reaches of space which was basically
krypton where they were just like a
super advanced race of people who had
basically done everything the the here's
a really dark aspect of the silver
surfers people right so the zen
lobbyians they had basically charted the
entirety of the universe they knew
everything there was to know there was
no more mystery in life so they actually
started killing themselves just to find
out what happens next just to have
something else to do right to see what
comes next it's pretty dark but you
could just say like they existed out
there somewhere and on his journey to
consume life-sustaining worlds galactus
came across as in law norm rad offered
himself he became a silver surfer rest
is history right so there's a lot that
you can do there with the character of
galactus but let me know what you guys
think right i mean obviously this is not
a super lengthy video it's not super
in-depth really more of just a theory
that i that i heard that i kind of
wanted to offer my own two cents on let
me know what you guys think right do you
guys think there's room for this kind of
thing or do you think galactus should
just be his comic book version the
survivor of a previous universe who made
his way into this universe and he's just
going around consuming life-sustaining
worlds because that's just his role in
in the cosmos right let me know what you
guys think but thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace